dazu bekommen zu den ersten guten hier
zwar mit dem alex zusammen
ein freund von mir
[Musik]
und wir haben uns mit nicht gedacht was
können wir gerade im haus machen und
haben uns entschieden für diese pflanzen
wand und diese pflanzen mann ist
wirklich genial einfach zu machen
pflanzen sorgen für ein richtig cooles
raumklima die luftfeuchtigkeit sie
filtern schadstoffe aus der luft damals
überlegt um alex zusammen das haben im
internet gesehen was wir da machen
können und haben uns für diese pflanzen
man entschieden
das ist wirklich einfach zumachen alex
wenn man überlegt einfach nicht mehr
sagt irgendwer sechs stunden gebraucht
für alles ja das ding zu streichen zu
wollen
gut vielleicht doch was organisieren
aber sehen dass auch wir sehen noch aber
ansonsten geht es wirklich relativ flott
und ihr müsst auch nicht nur wird ihr
französischer eiche nehmen ihr könnt
auch ein ganz normale was müssen auch
koloss mit mit paletten holzscheit noch
mit europaletten des zu machen ist auch
oder europaletten direkt an die wand zu
bauen und dann diese kübel höher zu
machen denke ich es ist kann jeder
machen
und wieder alex wie wir zweitens gemacht
haben das seht ihr nämlich der erste
schritt was da alex und nicht gemacht
haben ist wir haben uns einen
französischen platte geholt und zwar ist
rhi minute sich das alles noch mal kalt
sind genau kein parkett optik das kann
man sich bei jedem holzhändler holen
richtig genau richtig wird
wahrscheinlich sein vielleicht habt ihr
ja auch oben so eine große holzplatte
irgendwo liegen
ich meine so groß muss ja auch nicht
sein vielleicht wollt ihr auch nur meter
stähler 2 meter stück das heißt ich bin
irgendwie recht nehmen was da alex ich
und ich jetzt machen ist wir bauen das
jetzt einfach mal an
[Musik]
das ist jetzt wie la klasse palisander
das ist die farbe palisander und das ist
ungefähr die gleiche farbe wie unsere
treppen sind und da könnte wirklich
verschiedene farben holen das wichtigste
ist aber dass sie auf der rückseite
lässt dass es für den innenbereich ist
das ist ganz ganz arg wichtig wie gesagt
steht immer hinten drauf und jetzt
einfach mal kurz schütteln sagt ein
tolles auftragen
sollte alex trainings auf und tut es
jetzt mit einer spachtel verteilen und
zieht es richtig schön mit der spachtel
ab ihr seht gleich wird schon braun und
die öfter mal mit erlassen und drüber
geht umso breiter wird und wir müssen
wahrscheinlich sowie zwei mal drüber
gehen alex oder denkst auch zweimal
genau und die außenbereiche pinsel
einfach einstreichen und alex macht die
oberfläche jetzt hier gerade mit dem
spachtel schön gleichmäßig
[Musik]
doch den pinsel anstatt der karte jaja
so funktioniert aber optischen ja immer
wieder okay also schlich sich man kann
es noch mal kurz anschleifen nochmal
drüber gehen es muss schön gleichmäßig
sein auch mal ganz großen fläche seht
ihr sofort irgendwelche unebenheiten und
auch papa unterschiede
[Musik]
das haben wir gestern abend im alex
zusammen ist engagiert und ein trockenes
nach 20 minuten noch mal so wir haben
jetzt einfach feiern gemacht kommt dann
noch einmal vor und an und sagt komm wir
machen morgens weiter so das ding ist es
lanciert ihr seht auch wenn es dunkler
haben möchtet als das palisander dann
streichen nochmal drüber aber wir haben
gedacht das passt perfekt zum boden und
belastungs gerade so so und jetzt kommt
natürlich man muss es an der wand
befestigen ich meine wir haben etwas
riesengroß ist ein riesengroßes brett
hier
und wenn er es zu hause macht kommt
natürlich immer darauf an was wenn der
wand gehabt
wir haben zum beispiel in manager sind
bei uns in aus kalksandstein die sind
richtig stabiler mir ganz ganz hohe
dichte deswegen haben wir uns direkt im
normalen übel hin um normalen schrauben
mit einer vorrichtung genau so was
willst du überlegt haben wie kann man es
am besten an der wand anbringen man kann
auch eine unterkonstruktion bauen aber
wie gesagt kein schnell jemand direkt an
die wand und dann zeigen was man gemacht
haben und zwar haben wir hier einen
pfosten bohrer richtig alex wie marc
foster und mit diesen posten bohrer tun
wir uns nochmal an senken ist zeigen wir
mal ganz kurz und zwar kurz an setzte
genau senkrecht nach unten und bohren
jetzt zählt es habe eine senkung gemacht
und zwar werden ich jetzt nachher das
kann ja auch jetzt gleich machen und
zwar sechs abbott durchbohren
[Musik]
und jetzt können wir eigentlich die
schraube nachher in der mitte mit der
wand befestigen und zwar hier einfach
durchdrücken
naja da geht die schrauben nachgezogen
nachher sagen hat ja schon den kopf sie
genau das schon gut die verschwindet
nachher und dann haben wir diese tablet
apps oder beim schwedisch heißt apple
dann machen wir diese kluft und da sieht
man die schrauben nicht mehr und dann
gehen wir gerade noch mal mit der
palisaden lastwagen noch mal drüber und
dann haben wir eigentlich schrauben
versteckt das ist eigentlich sache eine
ästhetische sache müssen dass man die
schrauben gelöst dass man die schrauben
nicht sid ich würde sagen wir wollen sie
das nicht sieht und deswegen wie gesagt
im fonds labor vor gesenkt dass wir nach
handicap wieder reinkriegen
und jetzt holen wir alex zusammen
einfach mal alles vor born uns
vorbereiten bevor wir dann unser
konstrukt nach oben bringen ok
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt der schwierigste part
der ganzen geschichte jetzt wird es
nämlich richtig spektakulär
das problem ist folgt ist wir kriegen
diese riesen platte nicht durch den
dritten gang nicht die treppen hoch
obergeschoss kommt dass nichts weiter
und schoss ins obergeschoss nichts
zweite obergeschoss und wie
kriegswichtigen treppen gang
deswegen müssen muss über der garage
über balkon rein tragen und das ziemlich
200 kilo ist riesengroß und dazu brauche
ich meine freunde und hier habe ich
extra meine ganzen freunde gerufen die
mir dann helfen das ding jetzt hoch zu
bringen
da ist dann jungs manchmal warum bist du
da muss ich meine freunde
du hast keine freunde du hast keine
freunde tun hat so wie man es nur zu
wenn wieder hoch mache habe ich meine
freunde hier haben hat keiner gesagt
machen wir das gibt's doch nicht ein
einziger und eschau juni dagegen ist ihr
so schwach der krieg ist nicht okay wir
sind doch kein extremist freude hier
vielleicht helfen wir es möglich dass
brad hoch zu schleppen okay mir auf mein
kommando
okay ich bin okay
[Musik]
hat jemand schon mal knoten gemacht
hier ist blöd lass ich sie wieder mut zu
kleine junge habe es geschafft
wahnsinnig das war unglaublich
ingenieurskunst was ich dann wieder
gemacht habe wahnsinn war es meine idee
[Musik]
nur vorgegeben werden
alex hat jetzt vorgebohrt und jetzt
brauchen noch mal richtig rein und dann
haben wir ein dübel rein oder befestigen
muss man richtig
[Musik]
das ist ein übel das heißt wenn wir eine
rettung rhein main board nach herne
schrauberei macht wie immer mit dübel
und zwar die schraube fährt hier rein
und ein verrücktes und der amisen
ankauft sowieso lokale nachher in der
wand festkrallen so einfach rein und
oben auch komme ich nicht hin
das ist nicht bloß aber verschaffen
[Musik]
die wand ist das fest angebracht und
jetzt wo man die pflanzen anbringen das
sind zimmerpflanzen ganz normale und
jetzt tun wir so bohrungen machen das
ist zum beispiel haben wir was
zweckentfremdet
die bekannten rohrschellen da haben wir
diesen gummi schutz weg gemacht wie
werden wir jetzt so an der wand
anbringen und dass wir die pflanzen
nachher ein tag hier sagt einfallen
lassen so sieht es nachher der ganzen
warnte aus und da gibt es verschiedene
möglichkeiten was da alex hier auch noch
hat es sind hier
diese diese drähte und da was machen wir
da alex ist ja einen schönen balkon
gedacht genau gelände einzuhängen aber
da haben wir zu lösen
ich komme auch in die wand schrauben und
dann hebt das genau zu machen lässt und
wie wir die glanz jetzt am besten
positionieren
dafür habe man kat band geholt und jetzt
einfach mal die klappe nochmal
positionieren dass man ein bisschen wie
wir die pflanzen am besten aufhängen
oder
oben machen wie er die run wohl selber
wasser holt und wendigen gießen weil da
komme ich oben nicht mehr hin verstehste
deswegen machen wir die die gv gefäße
machen wir oben und die anderen machen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier diese rohrschellen
und zwar diese rolle da bot sich jetzt
das ja ins holz rein dann bleibt dieser
nippel hier übrig und da kann ich jetzt
einfach nachher auch drehen kommt hier
nach einer top- rein und dann ist es
fest und das machen bei allen töpfen von
gpus im amt ist und bei den anderen da
machen arbeiten mit bösen richtig alex
genau okay so hinten hat einen tag
aufsatz fox und jetzt hier rein
[Musik]
dann nehme ich hier die rolle muss jetzt
einfach drauf drin
das reicht ganz eine bank muss ich nicht
so platziert aufstellen von beiden
seiten bisher so muss ich haben jetzt
ein anderes system das ist normalerweise
eine bank gruppe bei so einem balkon
kübel wo mit einem balkon ich finde ich
auch cool das system und jetzt immer
hier diese die sie haken diese lösen und
die ösen machen jetzt auch an der wand
fest und hängen die nach hier ein
jetzt hatte alex noch mal ganz coolen
trägt er zeigen dass hier an auf der
wasserwaage jetzt weiß er genau den
abstand und jetzt bauen wir kurz ins
holz rein und haben perfekt den abstand
so jetzt habe ich ein ganz ganz kleinen
bohrer das ist passt der bohrer muss
immer ein bisschen kleiner sein als nach
eines gewinnen dass ich rein mache ich
ganz richtig
[Musik]
so jetzt können das einfach nur sagt cdu
perfekt
[Musik]
so werden alex gratis pflanzen an die
wand an bord bin ich hier am umtopfen
und zwar müssen verstehen wir im
baumarkt eine pflanze holt die
zimmerpflanze dann ist es meistens zu
viele pflanzen zu betrieb in einem topf
drin
deswegen kann oftmals sein dass die
pflanzen im baumarkt kaufte oder
irgendwo in den gärtnereien gärtnerei
passiert es normalerweise nicht die
wissen dass das da zu viel platz in
einem topf drinnen sind und das wichtige
ist die dinger rein umtopfen dass die
pflanze braucht luft und raum zum atmen
und zum leben
deswegen werde ich jetzt die pflanzen
umtopfen und einfach kleiner machen wir
keiner von euch wird wahrscheinlich eine
pflanze kaufen wo nur ein trieb drin ist
und zwar nehme ich hier diesen topf hier
seht ihr die ganze betriebe hier guck
mal hier sind viel zu viele trends es
zeit mal kurz drauf kommen guck mal hier
sehen 1 234 stück könig damit ich bin
vier töpfe damit machen und jetzt
nämlich das einfach kurz und steckt sie
in eimer voll wasser saugen sich mal
richtig schön fest dann hole ich sie
raus stellen sie ihr drauf und jetzt
keine angst haben jetzt baue ich das
ding einfach auseinander
jetzt habe ich hier ein trieb perfekt
jetzt nämlich einen kleinen topf hier
ein bisschen anzuchterde rhein setzte es
hier rein
so müssen feuchtigkeit noch dann habe
ich hier so 1 gewo behält das zeige euch
mal den hat mir der rudolf zugeschickt
dann gehen wir kurz zusammen in die
küche und zeigen euch mal wie ist die
säle mit ihren kräutern macht das ist
sehr dass mit den töpfen funktioniert
das ist meiner frau in der küche und
zwar hat ja auch gerade überall diese
kräuter die wachsen bei uns wie verrückt
das problem ist meine kräutern und du
vergisst eigentlich zu gießen oder du
gehst so viel und eigentlich eigentlich
so dass die pflanze sich eigentlich
immer wasser holt wenn sie gebraucht und
deswegen sehen wir hier zum beispiel
auch hier den schwimmer wieder wie
vorhin drüben und die die pflanze in dem
fall
petersilie glatt habe ich recht später
sehr glatt holt sich das wasser selber
und so einfach funktioniert und genau so
machen wir es bei uns an der ganzen land
nur ohne kräuter mit normalen
zimmerpflanzen sind nämlich die hier
diesen pfaden zu den top 4 1
und hier wedelt es stecke ich das in den
topf ist jetzt drin
und jetzt kommt dieser behälter er wird
jetzt drauf gemacht und da wird es mit
wasser gefüllt und der faden zieht durch
die capital kräfte
das heißt die pflanze nimmt sich hier
wirklich das wasser selber und begann zu
wachsen und dann müsste ich nur einmal
oder einmal in der woche wenn überhaupt
einmal in der woche hier wasser
auffüllen ihr seht es dann hier nach
einer wasserstandsanzeige schon mal kurz
was auffüllen das macht natürlich
saubere nachher sauberes wasser und
putzt das macht es richtig schön und so
wie es nachher aus die grünpflanzen
verbessern auch nachweislich das
raumklima sie produzieren sauerstoff und
sorgen für ausreichend luftfeuchtigkeit
viele zimmerpflanzen filtern sauerstoff
aus der luft und sind in der lage
gesundheitsgefährdend substanzen wie
formaldehyd benzol zu speichern
das formaldehyd das findet ihr euch auch
ganz ganz oft auf möbeln also diese
beschichtung auf möbel das meistens
formaldehyd drin und pflanzen zbv die
reinigung mit ist das raumklima wie eine
pflanze im raum stellt dann tut wirklich
die pflanze innerhalb von einer stunde
die ganze luft drin filtern und
speichern also die ganzen schadstoffe
das heißt pflanzen im haus zu haben sind
was richtig genial ist und das war auch
der hintergedanke warum ich mir überlegt
habe sony sony warnt die pflanzen man zu
machen
[Musik]
jetzt nehmen wir die löcher wenn wir
sagen wir mal nicht haben nachher diese
nachher nicht sehen da mache ich ein
bisschen acryl rein das ist klar
und natürlich sehr einfach nur ein
kleben perfekt
das hat jetzt der grünen hat das grüne
hat das mit palisaden lasse angemalt und
es hält jetzt einfach sieht jetzt auch
schön aus jetzt immer fällig und jetzt
manchmal ist meine frau dazu sagt schadt
kommst du kurz
ich finde da kann ich jetzt da kann ich
doch cool ich finde dazu kann ich noch
aufkleber kauft mein zuhaus kreidetafeln
danach aufstellen was eine pflanze lässt
ist das ist gut wieder oben die muss man
nur gelegentlich dies weil sie es war
sehr selber holen
aber ich komme da nicht hoch es mussten
auch hier bald sieht es doch cool aus
oder vor allem ich denke ich mal dass
ich gutes raumklima mit passen und man
kann jetzt zum beispiel können wir jetzt
auch noch im sommer noch ein paar hin
machen wo so richtig coole blumen sind
das noch und wird richtig zugewachsen
im wintergarten der hut und ist ganz
einfach gemacht und es war sogar willst
dich okay ich hoffe das erste turnier
selbst mit dem alex zusammen bin bin ich
auch mal ein paar mal aufgetaucht hat
euch gefallen
und wenn ein paar vorschläge habt sagt
uns bescheid was wir machen was wir
basteln können wir werden demnächst im
garten machen
ja ja ja was man in meinem garten machen
ja viele sache okay wir machen viele
seinen garten schalter filmer wieder
heim gibt es den daumen nach oben und
kein nach unten hätten die anderen und
macht's besser
ok alles da machts gut und abonniert uns
also ja alex mehr als gedacht ist videos
zu ende ist es aber nicht und zwar ich
bin dem rathaus in zukunft und zwar die
zukunft hat mir gesagt drei wochen
später
es ist richtig angewachsen alles aus mir
gemacht haben
ich sehe es ist richtig hektisch
geworden und das einzige was eigentlich
war eine blume hat läuse gehabt musste
ich dann entsorgen
und jetzt hat meine frau einfach den
wunsch geäußert dass sich noch mehr
pflanzliche macht ihr war es einfach zu
wenig und um mehr pflanzen hin zu lange
habe ich mich heute geholt von der
johanna und marie und johanna marie die
sind hier die machen gerade ihren girls
day und zwar seit zwölf jahre alt
richtig genau und die stufen heute bei
uns rein weil wir haben ja verschiedene
handwerker hier also bin ich da alex
oder den top ten frank ist ein
mediengestalter und den mädels möchte
ich einfach zeigen das handwerk auch was
cooles ist und ich hoffe ihr zwei
hälften wir jetzt die wand noch komplett
fertig zu machen so das ist dass er die
nachher auch richtig gut gefällt
gefallen hat es ja eigentlich schon und
die mädels und ich wir machen jetzt noch
mehr pflanzen hin oder dann schauen wir
uns mal an wie es im endeffekt noch
aussendet okay
wer jetzt genau umstellen und rauschen
herbig
[Musik]
dieser
setzt nur die rein wo blume hier ist es
auch und jetzt umdrehen mit dem
schraubendreher jobs reizt
[Musik]
perfekt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auch die mädels kommen jetzt die rolle
es ist aber gut wie mit der 2
ich finde es jetzt richtig cool als am
anfang fand ich so ein bisschen noch zu
leer
aber jetzt kann nicht mehr richtig gut
forscher dass wir also ich finde jetzt
schon wunderschön und wenn dann die
pflanze noch ein bisschen wachsen
ich hab da echt super gemacht fehlen
fehlen dann ganze geschichte ist das
zwölfjährige so groß sind oder denken
sie nicht wahrscheinlich wusste nicht
dass ja und wir machen jetzt weiter wenn
georgstr und wir gehen runter und guck
mal was die jungs machen okay und ich
hoffe ja keinen spaß gehabt an den
ganzen video und wir sehen es zunächst
beim nächsten update oder mit 30 waren
übrigens auch so groß wie ich aber mit
meiner schwester
habt ihr echt toll gemacht sieht super
aus
[Musik]